in this video we'll talk about MHC class
1 versus MHC Class 2 this particular
concept is for USMLE step one quick
revision Immunology these are high yield
and short Concepts so stay tuned till
the end
class 1 MHC molecule has one long chain
and one short chain the long chain
contains alpha 1 Alpha 2 and Alpha 3
segments the short chain is basically
the beta 2 microglobulin the class 2 MHC
molecule has two equal limb chains two
alpha and two beta chains so they are
structurally pretty much different
class 1 MHC is found in any nucleated
cell whereas the class 2 MHC molecules
are generally found on professional and
design presenter cells such as dendritic
cell macrophages or B cell
class 1 MHC and classroom MHC molecules
displays different types of antigen
class 1 displays generally endogenous
antigens or sometimes viral peptides
Class 2 MHC molecules generally displays
exogenous antigen or pathogen derived
antigens
the structural differences of class 1
and Class 2 MHC can be understood if we
look them from a top view their peptide
binding grooves are quite different
class 2 MHC can accommodate bigger
peptide ranging from 13 to 18 amino acid
long whereas class 1 MHC molecule can
only accommodate 8 to 10 amino acid long
peptides due to the constraint in the
MHC binding Groove
class 1 and Class 2 MHC molecules are
encoded by different Locus so there is a
different HLA Locus known as like mhc2
cluster HLA Dr DM DP all of these things
encode for Class 2 MHC molecules whereas
MHC class 1 molecules are encoded by
completely different Locus
so these are all the differences for
class 1 and Class 2 MHC molecules
summarized for your uh convenience so I
hope this video was useful you can get
more notes and flashcards in my
Instagram and Facebook page links are in
the description
you can also support our Channel using
paytm PayPal or UPI see you in next
video